hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to paranormal what huh uh
huh okay anyway so we I being me I know
I'm so great it seems like there
tomorrow anyway I had recommended this
game a lot by a lot of people so I
thought I'd give it a try uh thirsty um
I don't know what that is
okay let's dive right in if the guest if
the game is too scary hide they'll find
you anyway though
Oh hmm
paranoia Friday July 1st 2011 no it's
not hello my name is Mattel Clark by
Mattel I'm an artist and I've come to
believe that my house is haunted
Oh lately things have been going bump in
the night
haha a lot okay so I've set up cameras
around my studio and I've got one here
and I've started recording things to try
and prove to people that I'm not going
crazy
you're awfully short ain't you this is
the studio um this is where the magic
happens
don't mind the posing mannequins I
picked those up at Amazon they helped me
visualize a 3d space when I'm working on
my sculptures so not mannequin some
works in progress over there on the mat
hopefully something will happen here in
a second really trying to show that this
is real and that I'm not trying to get
famous on the Internet
I am
uh okay I get it
i'ma tell our artist
no hang hey hi uh boy hi whoa whoa hey
car
oh I'm back August 11 1984 I'm not alone
in this house I can feel Marcus watching
who knows about Jerry he knows about the
baby everybody will just wondering with
Cranston who sound like a hog it is my
celebrating district 19 with a fury I
woke up this morning a fire Jerry dead
in the bathtub
the Animus way of doing justice he
killed his own brother my only reason
for living as the baby okay September 7
and 23 the lights keep circling the
banging noises where my doors keep Sam
this is everybody September 7 things you
kill me or I kill the baby I don't even
care just stop the pain and I'm nice I
hate him I hate Oh Marcus I hate you
starting with this one
what the hell was going on in here ah
door
okay I feel bad for making fun of this
guy cuz this is his house in them oh
hello kind of freaking God a freaky
though didn't build it un poco freaky yo
hi oh you're gorgeous
ah crap what's supposed to be a below
what the hell I knocked it over
whoops sorry it's my art I'll do
whatever I want what is that
so some writing okay
I wonder what happens when I run out of
camera battery Oh what dumb okay yeah I
wanted to do that
I already activated it just F is
flashlight in every single game for the
rest of eternity
alright nothing spooky up here if
they're like I don't have any objectives
right I don't think there's any like
thing I'm supposed to do other than try
to find paranormal Oh
okie-dokie batteries are getting low now
I better charge it when I go to bed
tonight
man you've you've got to be like super
short man is everything seems I level to
you unless you're holding your camera
like at your chest starting to be day
soon I guess oh hello Oh No
what is that
okay weird
what the hell well-to-do finish atlas
fix basement lock fix screen door jam
clean car put groceries away take a bath
Google home history trash dog food watch
TV sleep the day away sleep the day away
sleep tough open da hai o hotel ah water
interesting what okay why is this blue I
need to go on my camera why I suppose
whoa hey stop that it's not that you're
just being a douche alright I guess I'll
go find it
bed close the door there definitely
weird noises for sure I got these short
little stubby legs whoa whoa whoa what
the hell whoa uh-oh
Oh what do I know what happened I don't
even know what why I'm dirty confused
what ha
how happened I'm like I did I guy I
think something grabbed me and cut my
head off game crashed anyway oh man
let's say that again I have no idea what
was going on there all right scraps in
three two one
ping all right new game look around for
diary entries from the previews owner of
the home this seems a waste maybe
because I didn't get maybe because I
didn't get to bed before my camera ran
out it's a Friday
ok July 1st 2011 hello hello tell Clark
my name is douche McGee Nerdist and why
do sure leave that my house is haunted
I rub feces on canvases and call it
harrowing bumping it's art don't tell me
it's not our so I've set up cameras
around my studio studio I've got my
feces art and I've started recording
things to try and prove to people that
I'm not going crazy are no I'm not do do
um this is where the magic happens ok ok
don't mind the posing mannequins I
picked those up at Amazon they help me
visualize a 3d space when I'm working on
my sculptures dry some works in progress
over there on the mat hopefully
something will happen here in a second
okie dokie Ellie trying to show that
this is real and then I'm not trying to
get famous on the Internet uh-huh so how
are you in your basement without a
camera in the first place
ok so definitely gonna hurry up hey lose
computer here look what a slob
I guess you can't suppose that a fecal
metal matter a fecal matter artists like
Mattel here is gonna be all about the
cleanliness
okay so turn off the water there's a
phone over [ __ ] I can't even jump here
oh I can sprint though woosh wowie Zowie
oh that's no good car started weirdly
doing side note is gone okay I must have
counted it that I read it before I'm
gonna go upstairs see if there's
something up there than I need up that's
the feet again
gnarrk splurt splurt yeah door yeah
that's kind of weird don't you think oh
whoa whoa whoa I don't know what was
that hey I'm getting like tossed around
here I'm not doing that
get off of me don't cut my head off
again don't hey back off whoa Hey look
okay hi
all right the hell was that dark in your
bathroom you really are an artist aren't
you why am I being tossed around so much
August 11th 1984 I read that I read that
all right
August 11th night sploosh blueish hi
turn the lights off hello hi
hmm me no likey turn light on okay ooh
ooh gee bored by bad idea M hey are whoa
see almost had me Oh Marcus okey-dokey
Marcus Oh
No what was that I just get
why is my camera so shaky shaky why is
the sounding so nervous for me
why are the doors keep opening slowly
why am I so weird eh why am i such a
weirdo my question whoa whoa I'm serious
my camera is going all over the place
here
haha no get out of here throw you
batteries you're getting low
I better charge I want to go to bed
tonight okay I'll go to bed now ah
mother punch ha
what the hell was that
hmm don't like this I'm going to bed not
a bad idea
ah lay my head down there Oh
oh I didn't close my door did I
okay can I what duh okay that's cool hi
so I just wake up during the night again
oh how did you get how wait a minute
some prankster alright I'm actually all
out of time man
this game is something else I hope it
saves my progress I have no idea but
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this in the comments below click my
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always we'll see you in the
next part
bye bye